das hat er nicht getan hat aber noch mit
luca herzlich willkommen wir heute zu
einem neuen video habe vor einigen tagen
schon ein video zu einem pokémon go heck
hochgeladen kann auch auswählen jetzt
beispielsweise mit ob ich jetzt im auto
beispielsweise sein sollen wenn ich
jetzt wie drücke sich schon nicht laufe
relativ schnell dem heck den ich mir
darunter geladen habe war es halt
möglich dass man am pc sich in seinen
account einloggt und dann damit
herumlaufen kann jetzt habe ich
allerdings ein video gefunden wollen typ
das ganze auch ein komplett neues level
gebracht hat der titel des todes spaß
überhaupt keine lüge denn das ist
wirklich der überaus krasseste beste
hyper tollste pokémon bohème den sg
irgendwie gegeben hat ich habe noch nie
so etwas krasses gesehen ich meine
freunde man kriegt pokémon dies nicht
mehr im spiel gibt aber wir fangen
machen das original gameplays von einem
youtube user name ist fast ich habe euch
das gameplay das originalvideo in der
beschreibung verlinkt und er fängt quasi
das video damit an dass er zu einem
poker stop hin laut dieser volkes top
ist ein modifizierter pokerstop von ihm
also eher den da wahrscheinlich
hingesetzt und hat er seinen namen
reingepackt dann dachte ich mir halt
erstmal so case soll ja irgendwie
möglich sein sich bei pokemon go eigene
pokerstop zu holen für sein unternehmen
für seinen kaffee oder so leicht hat er
das ja auch gemacht und dann dreht er
halt den poker stop und ich meine seht
einfach selbst was er dann bekommt
vier maß tabelle ein fucking kg dresden
scheiß punkte und chris vier master
welle weiß was ich kriegen trank und
belebe aber okay ich weil ich gönne es
ihm soll diese meister bälle haben ich
bin mittlerweile level 25 und habe noch
nie einen einzigen master bekommen aber
es ist in ordnung freunde es ist
wirklich in ordnung ich meinen solange
nicht irgendwelche legendären pokémons
damit nehme fünf geht es den punkt raus
und kriegt einfach so zwei millionen
youtube ich bin traurig dann klickt der
spieler halt auf dem youtube drauf und
geht dann quasi den kampfhund hat dann
halt erstmal standardmäßig einen
überfall ausgewählt geht dann aber in
seinen beutel und was sieht man da 45
meister werden willst du mich verarschen
ich bin froh wenn ich gerade mal ein
paar bälle darin habt ihr best body
board die ultimate level of performance
with which any way pokémon mail
klingt ja cool kann es mir vielleicht
ein paar up gib mir ein dank an dieser
stelle an alle gedacht okay diese meist
tabelle er soll meister denn
funktionieren weil in dem spiel auf dem
gameboy was also drückt auf einen knopf
der meister als liegt und er ist halt
das pokémon das automatisch drin und ich
muss jetzt nicht was ist denn wenn man
daneben wird aber das zeigt er uns jetzt
halt wie das funktioniert der ball
fliegt direkt auf das pokémon zu egal wo
man ihn hinwirft
wie gesagt krieg ich auch ein paar so
sieht das denn jetzt aus nachdem er den
meisten bälle auf das bei youtube
geworfen hat
und hier meine damen und herren haben
wir jetzt wirklich welt weil das erste
footage davon wie sich newton in dem
game anhört
dann fängt jetzt ein zweites youtube und
so sieht das dann halt aus nachdem man
das menü zu gefangen hat im menü und
schaut euch mal die cp von dem newton
also die sbe 801 sich das ist nicht
kratzt aber schaut wie bei unten diese
leiste noch ist das youtube ist high
level locker auf 5 6000 oder so
unwirklich freunde zu diesem zeitpunkt
dachte ich mir okay ich gönne dir dass
ich mein youtube ist jetzt mein
lieblingsbuch man meine lieblings
pokémon sind eher so dass acht labors so
also hast du schon so mein lieblings
pokemon ein paar sekunden später
du kannst dir auch noch fangen einfach
so alle drei nebeneinander mit bankern
traurig hier dann ist er halt im kampf
mit dem athos und jetzt seht ihr mal die
skills zu diesem spieler wenn er keinen
weiß dabei benutze dann ein hyper ball
du weißt auf jeden fall wie funktioniert
der gal
danach wirft da halt seinen nächsten
hyper ball und das war wirklich ein ganz
normaler straif hoch es war kein
klassischer wurf es war kein großartiger
kein reinfall farbe haben das waren ganz
normaler stinknormaler wurf nicht mal
einen körper und ich meine als ich das
game soll das erste mal gesehen habe
habe ich mir gedacht wege selbst wenn
ich 1000 mit dem hyper also fangen will
haut ist sofort ab und flieht und naja
sehen einfach selbst
du bist echt mich macht sowas wirklich
traurig positionsdaten in dem menü aus
ja und jetzt fängt da halt die anderen
pokémon die da noch waren zu diesem
zeitpunkt des videos danzig mit einer
halb wirklich okay das video geht jetzt
vielleicht noch so drei minuten der
lover jetzt noch ein bisschen darüber
sagt so wie er das gemacht hat
entschuldigt sich dafür dass er gehängt
hat aber nein wir haben ja nie vergessen
der ist einfach rumgelaufen und um ihn
herum spawnen immer übel fielen you also
der waren locker 100 - um den raum
ich bin froh wenn ich kein juli aus dem
zehn kilometer bekommen
natürlich vielleicht auch noch ditto
also freunde ihn mal reicht aber auch
das war vom heutigen video meine damen
und herren ich wollte mich aber auf
diesen hack reagieren das ist einfach
der krank beste weg den ich je gesehen
habe in bezug auf pokémon group werde
euch das video gefallen dann freut mich
immer leicht schaffen wir oft keine
ahnung bleibt einfach wenn es euch
gefallen hat ich heiß laser luca auf
snap chat instagram und musical i findet
auch in der beschreibung kommentiert mal
bitte